[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing one of the fabled hallows
the resurrection stone and whether or
not the possibility exists
that it has some kind of connection to
the veil inside the death chamber
the department of mysteries in case you
don't already know
the resurrection stone is of course one
of the fabled
deathly hallows the deathly hallows are
all powerful magical artifacts
stemming from the tale of the three
brothers antioch
cadmus and ignotus and their altercation
with death the three brothers were all
members of the famed wizarding family
the peripherals and their claim to fame
was their ability to cheat death
or so they thought at least for a short
period of time
after conquering death a personification
of death
under the guise of congratulating them
awarded them with three gifts
the elder wand the resurrection stone
and the invisibility cloak
each brother chose one of the gifts that
death had presented them
ignotus the youngest chose the
invisibility cloak
cadmus the middle brother chose the
resurrection stone
and antioch the eldest chose the elder
wand
in this video we're going to be more
closely taking a look
at the resurrection stone from the tail
of the three brothers
then the second brother who was an
arrogant man decided
that he wanted to humiliate death still
further and asked for the power to
recall others from death
so death picked up a stone from the
riverbank and gave it to the second
brother
and told him that the stone would have
the power to bring back the dead
the stone is said to be the only object
that could bring back the spirits of the
holden's deceased loved ones
activating when turned three times in
the user's hand
so naturally when harry gets a hold of
it he uses it
to summon some of the loved ones that he
had lost
he uses it to summon his mother father
sirius and even remus they were neither
ghost
nor truly flesh he could see that they
resembled most closely the riddle
that had escaped from the diary so long
ago and
he had been memory made nearly solid
less substantial than living bodies but
much more than ghosts
they moved toward him and on each face
there was the same loving smile
james was exactly the same height as
harry he was wearing the clothes
in which he had died and his hair was
untidy and ruffled
and his glasses were a little lopsided
like mr weasley's
sirius was tall and handsome and younger
by far than harry had seen him in life
he loped with an easy grace his hands in
his pockets and a grin
on his face lupin was younger too and
much less shabby
and his hair was thicker and darker he
looked happy to be back in this familiar
place
a scene of so many adolescent wanderings
lily's smile was widest of all
she pushed her long hair back as she
drew closer to him and her green eyes
so like his searched his face hungrily
as though she would never be able to
look at him
enough the shades that harry had
summoned were just like the people that
he'd imagined in his mind
the stone worked it brought them back
the catch
it doesn't bring them back properly it
only brings back the shades of these
people
giving the holder of the stone a mere
taste of what it's like to have these
people back
in their life the stone's inability to
properly cheat death
was death's way of punishing the
arrogant peveral brother
it just gave people a sample of what it
would be like to be reunited with these
people
and in cadmus case he killed himself to
be with the girl
that he loved once more all of these
associations with death
connected to a real-world tangible
physical object
reminded me of something else in the
harry potter universe
the veil on level 9 of the ministry of
magic
lies the department of mysteries the
section of the ministry
responsible for researching all of
life's great mysteries
love space thought time
death these were all areas of focus for
the department of mysteries
investigated by ministry workers known
as the unspeakables
inside of the department of mysteries
lies the death chamber
a large dimly lit rectangular room with
a sunken stone pit
however the most notable feature of the
death chamber
is certainly the enigmatic stone
structure known as the veil
the veil is an ancient stone pointed
archway
that serves as the barrier between the
land of the living and the land of the
dead
it's an ancient crumbling relic that no
one fully understands
and is the subject of much investigation
by the unspeakables
though inviting the archway is a one-way
trip
as if someone from the land of living
passes through it they inevitably die
sending messages through the veil is not
possible however
when the souls of the dead recognize a
loved one that approaches the veil
it has been expressed that they will try
to communicate
when living people into the veil they
appear to experience
a relatively pinned death almost as if
they are
in a high wind before simply falling in
it's also been expressed that once
someone begins to pass through the veil
they are beyond saving no one knows who
actually created the veil
as very little is actually known about
it but i have a theory
who better to create a barrier between
the land of living in the land of the
dead
than death himself we know from the
story of the deathly hallows
that the personification of death plays
a role in the wizarding world
and i can't think of a more suitable
candidate for the creation of such an
artifact
additionally i believe that the veil
itself has a connection
to the resurrection stone from the tail
of the hallows
both objects serve as gateways or
barriers
between those who are living and dead
the only difference is the achievable
level of communication
with the stone you can generate actual
physical shades
that you can directly interact with
whereas with the veil
it has been expressed that you can only
hear if you're listening closely
those from the land of the dead it has
also been expressed that you won't be
able to communicate back
that is unless you travel through the
veil reaching the points of no return
while neither harry's parents nor rumors
died by falling into the veil
i still feel like sirius death the hands
of the veil
reinforces this connection between the
veil and the stone
it seemed to take sirius and age to fall
his body curved in a graceful arc as he
sank backwards to the ragged veil
hanging from the arch harry saw the look
of mingled fear and surprise on his
godfather's wasted
once handsome face as he fell through
the ancient doorway
and disappeared behind the veil which
flooded for a moment as though in a high
wind
then fell back into place this is what i
think happened
we know that when cadmus and death have
their interaction the stomach death
gives cadmus was simply picked up
from the riverbank whether he enchanted
that stone right then and there
is up for you to decide but given that
the veil is constantly described as
crumbling cracked and so ancient that
it's amazing that it's still able to
stand
i think that the resurrection stone
might simply be a piece that broke off
sure the resurrection stone from the
film adaptation
looks quite polished but that could be
for any number of reasons
maybe the stone was smoothed and
seasoned after time in the riverbank
or maybe the resurrection stone was a
crest or
symbol that was attached to the top of
it either way
i think that there could be some kind of
connection there what do you guys think
are the veil and the resurrection stone
connected or are they independent
gateways of death
let me know in the comments section
below until next time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forgets to live
[Music]
you